Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show.
What you're about to hear is part three
of a three part conversation with Kevin
Kelly, Co, founder of wired magazine,
bestselling author all around
fascinating human being.
If you didn't catch the first two parts,
you might want to do that before
venturing in, but if not, no fear.
We answer a lot of questions.
It's a conversation you can pretty
much dip in and dip out as you'd like.
So if you don't mind, your stories is more
of a jigsaw puzzle, then by all means,
keep on listening. So without
further ado, please enjoy part three.
The final part of the Tim
Ferriss show with Kevin Kelly,
and thank you for listening
at this altitude, I can flat out for a
half mile before my hands start shaking.
Also,
I'm a cybernetic organism living
above too.
Perhaps jump into some rapid
fire questions and they
don't have to even be rapid
fire quest or the quiet, just some fire
questions. The questions will be rapid.
The answers can be as short
or as long as you'd like.
What book or books have you do you gift
or have gifted the most other people
outside of your own books?
There is a short graphic novel by Daniel
Pink Cold Juco and it's career counsel
advice. It's aimed at young
people. It's a graphic novel.
It's a cartoon and basically,
and it's Andy young people is trying
to teach them how to be become
indispensable and I've given that away
to young people because it's for me the
best summary of it. Again, it's
not like how to become successful.
It's how to become indispensable to,
that's right. It's a adventures of Johnny
Bunko or something like that. Yeah, yeah,
that's right. That's right. I have that
on my bookshelf back in San Francisco.
In fact,
yeah.
If you know a young person who is
just starting out, hand him that book,
it's very easy for them to read cause
graphic novel. It's non nonthreatening.
It's fun and it will give us
like five great principals for,
I'm starting out and helping them kind
of orient themselves as a start working
in,
in the working life.
For someone who's facing a lot of
the same questions, let's just say,
so you have graduates asking the
what should I do? Why am I here?
What am I good at?
If we fast forward to say for the sake
of argument and mid thirties right?
People in Middle Age hitting
that particular point.
Are there any books that you
would recommend they read?
There is a book that I'm recommending
like cal Newport is called so good they
can't ignore you.
This changed my mind because I had
kind of bought into the kind of new age
California dogma,
a follow your bliss,
you know the money will follow and he
makes a really good argument and convinced
me actually not very good advice that
what you really want to do is to master
something and to use your mastering
of something as a way to get to your
passion.
So if you start with just passion,
it's sort of paralyzing because,
and I know this from my own kids,
they have 18 they really don't
know what they're passionate about.
I mean some people are lucky enough
to know and a lot of people aren't.
So this is,
this is a book for people who don't
kind of really know what they're really
excellent at.
I don't really know what
they're passionate about
and his premise is that you
master something almost anything at all.
It just something you master and you use
that mastery to kind of move you into a
place where you can begin to have passion
and that you kind of keep recycling
that the way you find your passion is
through mastery rather than the other way
around,
which is people think that they're going
to get their mastery through passion
and I kind of believe that former,
you know that Matt and the
passion would lead to mastery,
but after thinking about it,
looking at his examples in his argument,
I'm pretty sure that for these,
for most people you can
get to your passion through
mastery and that would also
give you a currency or a lever
to use in getting to that point.
Exactly. Excellent. Do you have
a favorite fiction book? Yes.
Fantastic.
I usually don't get one answer,
and this is great shot to Ron
shots.
It might take me a way to explain this,
but it's,
it's a one author wrote one book
cause it's very autobiographical.
The premise of the book and the author's
life seems completely incredulous and
kind of almost Hollywoodish.
But what you get from it and the
where it's set, it's set in India,
sets in the slums of India
and you get a credibly vivid,
immersive deep and in some
ways uplifting view of India.
And the underworld in India
ended that part of Asia.
And the, the main protagonist is
this very interesting zen criminal.
He's sort of a coyote trickster
blend of someone who is,
you know,
he does bad things but at the same time
he's sorry about it and he has a kind of
a cosmic perspective.
It's very, very unusual.
But it's a long book and I actually
recommend that people are going to try to,
is it you actually to get the
audible version listened to it.
It runs like, you know, on and on. But
it'd be one of those books that you,
that you wish will never end. And I'll
just tell you the beginning of it,
which is that, and this is the
true part, which is that the guy,
the author became a bank robber in
New Zealand. He was hooked on drugs,
started robbing banks,
was eventually caught and escaped from
prison and he made his way to the slums
of India where because he had a medical
kit, he was treated as a doctor,
gotten involved and hooked on drugs in
India. I got involved with the mafia,
was put into prison,
tortured, left, abandoned,
nobody knew and even in there
started writing a book. He,
we have to wrote this book. They ripped
it up, destroyed it. He was recruited,
found a guru, an Afghany was recruited
and Ima Jean was fighting their kids.
Entire company was wiped out. I mean
this, that's just the beginning.
That's like the first day.
It's really interesting that you would
bring him Sean from for those people who
haven't heard of Josh Waitzkin.
I also had him on this podcast.
Josh was the basis for searching for
Bobby Fischer at the book and the movie
Worldclass Chess Player,
also very deep soulful guy.
And this is one of his favorite
books as well. Oh yeah, you would,
you would love Josh sometime.
I'll have to put you guys in touch,
but any favorite documentaries?
Well,
now you're,
you've asked the wrong question because
I have a site called true films for the
past 10 years I have reviewed the best
documentaries and actually have a book
called true films, which is the 200
best documentaries that you should see.
Oh my God, no kidding. Wow. You
have no idea how timely this is.
So it's to a t r u e films stuck up
true films.
And so I,
there are a couple of films that
I would say have sort of universal
appreciation.
Like you know,
they might have like a rating of like a
hundred or rotten tomatoes or something.
So the one documentary that I think
everybody that I know who've seen it,
his love to his man on wire,
such a good movie,
transcendent,
it's just a beautiful movie.
It's based on the fact that
this guy basically he's
going to walk to twin towers.
I mean he,
the moment was,
he was like 14 year old kid in France
was at a dentist office looking at a
magazine and he saw that they were,
had plans to build this twin tower in
New York and he saw those two twin towers
and he said, I need to walk between
them. He didn't know how to type,
walk the towers and not been built.
He was already planning this thing and
he was filming himself the whole way.
Yeah.
So amazing.
Okay. And so he does, he does it.
And how he does it is amazing.
So another great documentary that I
love because it's very unusual among
documentaries and films, the villain
side of the whole thing as well,
which is King of calm.
Oh I haven't, this has been recommended
to me. I still have not seen this.
King of Kong is about a guy
who becomes the video game,
arcade game, King of Kong.
He becomes the champion.
But he is basically competing against
this cabal of people who were trying suits
of vert him. And are doing all kinds
of really terrible things to stop,
which is all on film.
And so here's this really kind of
Midwest and really lovable guy and you're
rooting for him the whole time.
While these really sleazy guys
are trying to take him down,
it's just fantastic.
I have to watch that.
So that's the second one. The third one
is one that's not so well known but a,
it's called state of mind.
And it's about the
spectacles in North Korea,
which these two filmmakers had access to
when they filed several different young
athletes who were practicing
for the spectical.
And in the spectacles of course
what it is is people are pixels.
You know they have these like
huge stadium size things in there,
like a little robots that are cogs in
this machine, which is like perfect.
So you can imagine like you know like
a picture that's made up of pixels,
but every pixel is actually was a little
boy or girl holding up a card colored
cards in sequence. So these things
move, which means that, you know,
there's not a pixel missing. So let me
that nobody's sick is like, you know this,
you're not allowed to be sick.
You can't make a mistake at all,
and it's getting inside of North Korea,
which turns out to be a nationwide cult,
and I think that in 50
years when they're gone,
nobody will believe that
that was even possible.
And this documentary will
be there saying, no, no, no.
They really was a nationwide called
and they really did believe this.
It really is amazing to
see what's going on there.
All right, well I know, I know what
I'm doing for the next few days.
Next few evenings.
Well, I could go on unfortunately
because I have a lot of them,
but go to the truth. I only
review when's it are? Great.
So I don't do I just
saying these are fantastic.
Oh Man. All right. I've
been looking for this.
I cannot believe that I'm
only learning this now.
I'm kind of embarrassed about that.
When you think of the word
or hear the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Jesus.
All right.
Why would you say that?
Well,
there aren't that many people who've
left their mark on as many people in the
world as he has. I think what he
was up to, what he was doing, his,
you know, fastly been
twisted, misunderstood,
whatever word you want. But
nonetheless, what's remarkable is,
and here's the guy who
didn't write anything.
So I think success is also overrated.
Love you to elaborate on that.
Greatness is overrated. A lot of, you
know, I mentioned big numbers but she's,
but it's more of the impact
they had on people's lives,
but I think we tend to have an image of
success that's so much been skewed by
our current media.
It's like our sense of beauty.
I mean it's sort of like in terms of
all possibilities is in a very small,
narrow, defined his own kind of
ritualistic in a certain sense.
I think our idea of success is
often today. It means you know,
somebody who has a lot of money or who
has a lot of fame or who has some of
these other trappings which we assign
but I think can be successful in by being
true to and kind of being the most
you that you could possibly be.
And I think that's what I think of
is one of the things that Jesus,
whether you take them as just a historical
character or anything beyond was,
was about, he certainly wasn't imitating
anybody. I mean put it that way.
I mean I think that's the,
the great temptation that people
have is they want to be someone else,
which is basically they want to be
in someone else's movie. You know,
they want to be the best rockstar.
And there's so many of those already
that you can only went up imitating
somebody in that,
in that slot.
And I think to me the success
is like you make your own slot,
you have a new slot that didn't exist
before and I think that's of course it
would use as many others were doing.
But it was there were kind of making,
making a new slot and
that's really hard to do.
But I think that's what I chalk up
as success is you made a new slot.
What is your new slot?
You knew, you knew that was
guy who says I'm successful.
I mean I'm trying to not
make any assumptions here.
Or what would be your slot?
Well, my slide would be Kevin Kelly.
I mean, I mean that's the whole thing.
It's not going to be like a career or you
would really ideally be something that
was, you had no, no imitators. I mean
you would be who you are and that's,
that is success actually in some
senses is you didn't entertain anybody.
No one else had mutated you afterwards.
So you know, in a certain sense you
have, if you become an adjective,
that's a good sign. Right? So
I think success is actually,
you kind of make your own path. If they're
calling you a successful entrepreneur,
then to me that's not the best kind of
success because you're being confined to
the category, right? You're in a category.
If you could change one thing
about yourself, what would it
I could sing. You would
like to sing? Yeah.
I seem to be unable to carry a tune and
I can't remember when my wife can hear
something once and she can
just sing it back later. I,
I could hear the same song I have here
at the same song and I couldn't tell you
three notes of it.
I'm sure because I'm a Tim Ferriss Fan.
I'm sure I could train myself to
eat that. I know I could, but I,
I guess I haven't and it
would be something that I
have to really work at and I
haven't, but I have trouble
carrying it tunes, staying
in tune, remembering a tune.
I love music and I appreciate it,
but in terms of actually
singing and or play,
I don't play an instrument so maybe
I would say a little easier for me.
That'd be something nice.
Have you taken lessons or
attempted to take lessons? No,
I got it just in the spirit of trade.
I've recently started exploring
hand drumming with Jim,
Jim Bays and different types of drums.
If anyone out there can
get me a pan art hang,
I would really love to hear from you.
Those of you that will mean nothing
to most people are hearing this.
The research that has peaked my curiosity
most recently and of course you don't
want to run out and just
start swallowing these things,
but there's a common auntie
epilepsy drug called Valproate,
which apparently has some implications
for opening a window for achieving
perfect pitch in mature adults.
Very fascinating stuff. Wow. Uh,
south I five. I do any
experiments with that. I will,
I will certainly report back.
Well now that you've talked about it,
not the drug part,
but I did remember I did take one
class that you mentioned the drums.
It took a one class at a, an adult summer
camp, which are highly recommended.
If your kids go to camp, you should go
with them. And it was a steel drum. Oh,
cool. Course. And I
love that. So like you,
I think if I did take up an instrument
it would be drums of some sort.
Because of that, I seem to respond
to it and I did pretty good for the,
for the intro course on steel drumming,
I find percussion to be so primal.
Just satisfied some type of need
that probably predates, yes,
verbal communication even certainly
certainly written notes. Right.
Is your inner cave man just respond?
Are there any particular, let's just
say in the first two hours of your day,
any particular morning rituals or
habits you have that when performed
consistently you find produce better
days for you and I'm leaving better days
undefined on purpose,
but I love studying mornings and or
what people do when they wake up.
What time do you wake up?
Are there any particular habits or
rituals that you find contribute to better
days?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm a very good sleeper.
I don't sleep a lot these days.
I get up at seven 30
and I have some rituals,
but I don't vary them enough maybe
to to know whether they are a,
I'm not a morning person. Okay. To begin
with. You're not a morning person. Well,
I mean, well, the fact that
you don't vary them as perfect
necessarily optimized in any way or,
or I can't tell which is better,
but for better or worse when the first
things I do is I read the paper version
of the New York Times,
it's a kind of like a,
so what I call a guilty pleasure.
I don't know whether that makes me
better at anything else I do, but, um,
I don't drink coffee or anything
and this is sort of my, um,
it's a ritual and when I'm not here,
I don't read it.
So it's like I don't miss it. It's kind
of a hearing. Yes. But like if I'm here,
it's like I got to do it. I
don't know. It's kind of weird.
Is that immediately after waking you
read the paper or is there anything
can just about,
I just kind of in my pajamas,
I walk out to the front gate and I
pick it up and um, I read it. I mean,
and I don't read all of it.
I just kind of go through and I usually
don't even read the news part or read
the slower stuff. I make sure why, uh,
now that you're asking and that's it.
That's the entire ritual.
I don't have the same thing for
breakfast or anything like that.
It's just that morning hit.
Do you do anything throughout
your day regularly?
Maybe it's before bed
or anything else that,
that most other people probably don't do?
That's a
good question. Um, no, really. Okay.
I have no special sauce,
but you're very consistent.
You don't, your days seem
to be very, very widely.
So that in and of itself
might be something that a
lot of people don't. Okay.
Let's pick up two different,
while I'm here in this studio,
I have a lot of control over my time
and so what I do during the day is,
is greatly varied. I'll, you know,
I'll do a lots of things for short
amounts of times and you'll go into my
workshop,
I'll read,
actually read books it down and read
bookstore in the middle of the day.
I'll do a hike and bring
my camera almost every day.
It may be that it's something that
most people don't do as probably,
they probably aren't taking pictures with
a camera every day or reading books in
the middle of the day for that man. Right,
exactly. Well, maybe that's true. I guess.
How do you choose your books? Ah, that's,
that's a paradox of choice
probably for a lot of,
for a lot of people it is just like where
do you go listen to next one? Music,
I think the music becomes free and
everybody has all the music in the world,
but deciding what you're going to listen
to becomes the thing you pay for. And I,
and I,
this has been my prediction about Amazon
is that we're soon going to have like
any book you want for free, Amazon
prime, you digital version of it.
You can have it whenever you want,
but you will pay for us for the
recommendations. Um, that's a great point.
That's a great point.
I have a network of friends and I
listened to lots of podcasts so I get them
from all over the place and like probably
you are this point I long ago decided
that in terms of the
greater scheme of things,
the cost of books were really cheap
and if I wanted to book I would buy it.
And the result is I am right now speaking
in a two story high library of books
that they have and adult to the same
with digital books because I finally
figured out that, oh, you know, if
I purchase it do you could do two,
but before I'm reading it, it's not
going anywhere. It's just sitting there.
So I shouldn't really purchase a digital
book until like five seconds before I'm
going to read it.
I have exactly the opposite habit
because right, because it's like,
well it's there.
The whole point of kindle is that you
don't have to have it until like you need
it.
So on the digital books,
I don't buy anything until like
I'm seconds away from reading it,
then I'll get it.
But the paper books,
I was near to the point
of actually digitizing,
getting rid of all my paper books.
I was that close about five years ago.
But then I had an epiphany.
I went to a private library and I
realized that books were never as cheap as
they are today and there never will be
as cheap and that there's some power
about having these things in paper.
Always available,
no batteries, you know, never obsolete.
And that if you made a library now,
you would never be able to make
some of these libraries in 50 years.
And so I decided to keep and to kind
of cultivate this paper library as a,
you know, as something that was going
to be very powerful in the future.
I like that,
or
at least I can use it as a justification
for keeping a lot of paper books around.
I get tips from books,
from podcasts, from blogs,
from friends,
from Amazon recommendations anywhere.
And whenever I hear someone recommended
book, I'll go and check it out.
And then I'm fairly free in buying it.
But,
which means I read a lot
of really mediocre books.
Well that's part of my job,
right? That's cool tools.
The book that we were just talking about,
which is this catalog of possibilities
that I self published that has, oh,
I don't know, 1500, you know,
maybe there's a couple of hundred
books that are recommended,
but I probably read thousands
and thousands and thousands
of books in order to
select those.
So I see part of my job reading through,
and I read a lot of how to books. Most
of the books I'm reading is nonfiction.
And a lot of it is even
instructional stuff on, you know,
how to build a stone wall,
how to do Origami,
how to send a sale like micro
satellite into space. Whatever it is,
it doesn't matter. I will look at
it and I've seen tens of thousands,
if not 50,000, how to books over my
lifetime. I can spot a really good one,
but still I'll read through the,
um,
the other ones in order so that
someone else doesn't have to.
And I can recommend saying this is the
best book on building a tiny house.
If you want to build a tiny house.
Do you, when you read these
books on Origami or Stonewall,
do you follow through and attempt these
projects or are you evaluating it purely
based on your amassed
experience of reading lots of
these types of instructional
books?
No, actually, so maybe one of the
other things that I don't do every day,
but one of the things I do in general
that maybe everyone else is not doing is
that I have like a thousand hobbies.
I dabble in things.
So I have built stone walls more than one.
I have done Origami,
I have made beer, I have made wine,
I have, you know, whatever it is. I,
I've tried to do these things in my
life and I continued to try and do them.
I have homeschool my son, I have, and
so as much as possible, this is what my,
you know,
I was talking before about my day.
It's irregular in a sense that
I'm here and I have things,
but I'm doing new things and I'm
reading new things all the time.
So I'm in my outside, um, you know,
make a go card or we'll,
um,
do something that they haven't done
before and that's the basis for helping
decide about these books.
I don't have to be an expert in it,
but I can know enough to tell whether or
not the information they're telling me
is,
is useful.
What od project over the last
year has been the most fun?
Let's start there for you. Yeah. Well,
just the last couple of months, Charlie
built myself a real workshop and wish I
could show it to you because of the cool
things that did, it was, you know,
if you go onto like a you line or
somewhere is container businesses,
they have these racks of bins.
So I filled an entire wall of
hundreds and hundreds of bins,
so, so I can organize this stuff. And, uh,
I'm a big fan of Adam Savage and he has,
he has a principle for his
workshops called first order access,
which basically means that you don't
want to store things behind anything.
Everything has to be at the first
level so you can look and see.
It has to be within reach in the
sense that you have to be able to see
everything that you have
and it's accessible.
You don't want things hidden
behind other things. Right.
So that's part of what I was doing with
this workshop is this kind of first
order access. And it's true, this
really powerful. I mean I just,
the few days or the weeks I've had working
in it is just transforms everything.
It's like I had the same problem
with my books for many, many years.
I had books like on multiple different
bookshelves in the house ahead of inboxes
ahead,
I'm this and that and moving everything
to one location until library where
there was two stories, I could see
all my books just transform them.
It made it really useful because I could
find them just really go and reach for
them. And the same thing with
finding, bringing it to my tools,
which is that you want to have things
plugged in, ready to go, labeled,
organized first order access.
And it can make simple jobs really
simple instead of like the, you know,
the hours of looking for something,
right. Gathering all the
tools, all the tools.
And also it's just like what's happening,
like a manual random access memory.
Right.
You have your me some plots right in front
of you. You know the tools are, yeah,
that's very cool.
If there were one object,
manual project building something that
you think every human should have the
experience of doing, what would
that be? It was very easy.
We need to build your own house.
Which shelter and it's not that
hard to do. Believe me, I actually,
I built my own house. And your house is
amazing. I know that. Not this house,
I mean I actually built one
from cutting down the logs,
cutting down the trees in upstate New
York and doing the stone hers. And we,
you know, I mean unfortunately
I don't recommend this.
We made like two by fours from trees.
You don't want to do that because it's
a pain. Because you know, standard,
standard lumber is very,
it's very good. If it was,
things were awful little quarter of an
inch as they are with rough sawn lumber
is just, it's a mess. But nonetheless,
a large portion of the people in
the world have made their own homes,
Adobe rammed, earth,
bamboo, whatever it is.
And like going back to what we
originally started off with, um,
even if you don't wind up living in it,
it's empowering to know
that you can do it for,
if you do wind up living in it.
I have a friend Lloyd Khan who built
his magnificent place in Bolinas that he
built was salvaged material from,
from scratch over the many years.
It gives you the power to alter its.
So I believe that that your house
should be an extension of you,
that that really is another projection.
So another way of,
and also going back to what we're talking
about and another we have to who you
are and to discover what you're good at
and because a well designed house should
really reflect you. And,
and what I've discovered,
let people design houses and they have
this kind of imaginary fantasy idea about
themselves and what they're going to
do. Well, you know, whatever it is,
they're going to um, have
a swimming pool, you know,
it's like they're never going to use the
swimming pool, whatever it is. I mean,
very few people actually have a very good
sense of who they are and what they're
going to use something for.
But if you really study yourself and
really are honest and designed something,
that space can help you become successful
in the sense of making it a slot for
you, making your own
slot. And it's another,
it's both a kind of a byproduct of who
you are and also can help you because it
works both ways.
I like that. Right. You're
not just finding yourself,
you're creating yourself.
Exactly. And, and that, so this is
a larger philosophical question,
but this is something I talk about a
lot in a very high dimensional space,
which means like space of
many pending possibilities.
The act of finding in the act
of creating are identical.
There's no difference between discovering
something in inventing something.
You could be, we could say
that philosophically, you know,
Benjamin Franklin invented late tricity.
We could say that Christopher
Columbus invented America.
We could say that discovery and invention
are the same so that discovering
yourself in defending yourself is
really the same things bring about that
process.
You have to do both at once.
I really enjoy that.
Last question,
if you could give your,
let's say you can pick the age,
either 15 or 20 year old self,
one or a few pieces of advice,
what would they be?
You don't have to do everything yourself.
You can hire people to do stuff.
I wish I had known that
when I was younger.
I wish that I had when I was 20
working for whole earth catalog.
I wish I'd known that I could've
hired a programmer to do something.
I could have hired someone.
It took me a long time to understand that
and then recently I've been really big
on it. Hiring people
through e lance, you know,
because I came from a little bit
of kind of a duty yourself. I mean,
I made a nature museum when
I was 12 at a chemistry lab.
They built myself, you know, building the
stuff and I could buy in the classroom,
but I had a whole chemistry lab,
I had nature museums,
I did all this stuff and I did it myself.
And then of course,
moving into the whole earth catalog,
which was a kind of a do yourself thing.
I really was, um, you know, I just
talked about building my own house.
Well now I will hire
professionals to work.
And it just took me a long time to
realize that there's something about being
able to pay a professional to do what they
do really well is not like a weakness.
It's like it helps them. I'm
happy, they're happy, we're happy,
and I can do a lot more now.
There's certainly a pleasure in
doing things yourself in dabbling it.
But there's also this other thing, which
I didn't realize, which is there's,
there's this leverage that you get by
hiring people who are really good paying
them,
fairly,
working with them to amplify
what it is that you want to do.
And I wish I knew that when I was younger.
That's a fantastic answer. And
you have, if I remember correctly,
an assistant and a researcher. Is
that, is that still true? Yeah,
it's one of the same person. Oh,
they are the same. Okay. Yeah.
So I thought that at one point you had
believed that you needed those people to
be two separate people.
But
here's what I was saying was that it's
very unusual to find one person who can
do both of those tasks.
Both of those tasks are often not
found the same person because there's,
you know, the hunting, the
researching, the kind of,
there's a hunter aspect to research.
There's often found in a certain
personality and then they're kind of the,
the Admin is more of, um, you
know, your training kind of, um,
making sure things,
a gardening a little bit.
And so it's often rare to
find someone who can do both,
but as possible.
Was it luck that you happened upon this
particular individual that you work with
now or did you have a method for?
Was there a particular
approach that the forum for it,
uh,
found that the place where I found
over the 14 years I've had to,
the place where I found that there
were more likely than not to have a
combination was librarians.
I love it. That's fantastic.
So we uh, put out notices on the
librarian mailing lists and stuff.
That is fantastic. I said, last question,
this will be the last question is,
is there any other thoughts or advice
you'd like to leave with the listeners and
then where would you like
people to find more from you?
You're writing anywhere else?
I would say congratulations to the
people who are listening to the podcasts.
I think podcasts are of
this fantastic new medium.
I'm spending a lot of time there.
I think it's just really great.
We're in the early days
of where this would go.
I'm really impressed by the power of
this medium to teach and to inform
sometimes to entertain. Again,
I'm thankful to you, Tim,
for having me on and having
a chance to gab here,
but to the people who are listening, I
think keep going. Listen to more podcasts.
Uh, tried to go wide and know 10 mentions
them here and there. Take a chance,
listen to some more.
So that's one thing I would say.
And as far as finding out more about me,
I lucked out with a very easy website.
It's my initials,
KK,
kk.org I have very public
email for past 25 years.
You can find it very easily on my
website if you want to email directly.
I have not outsourced that.
Unlike other people that I know and
my writings and books and whatnot,
or at dub dub,
dub.
Dot kk.org cool tools is a book that I
really believe that each of you out there
should have. It's on paper. It's
sort of the best of the website.
Cool tools,
which has been going on for 11 years now,
where we review every
day one great tool there,
only positive reviews.
Why waste your time on anything but the
best and tools in the broadest sense of
the word of things that are useful,
whether it's a lance or a book on how to,
um,
do psychedelics or a book on how to build
a workshop or how to build a house or
how to hitchhike around the world.
I and others recommend the best here with
some great context and it's printed on
paper,
are available on Amazon.
Not so easily fan of bookstores cause
it because it's huge. I mean it's,
it's like, it's like five pounds
ways is really, really big.
And if you don't find like 500 things
in there you didn't know about that you
wish you knew about, like last year,
I'll give you your money back. So
enjoy that. So that's that. A cool
tools or cool tools and Amazon.
Excellent. Well Kevin, this
has been a blast. It always is.
Every time we chat I feel
like we should chat more.
So hopefully we'll get a chance to spend
some more time together soon back in
nor cal or somewhere else.
I know Orange Shyna it's been a long time.
I could get back.
I'm ready.
I'm headed back to Japan again.
And I know that you have lots of roots in,
in Asia, but, um,
I go there to renew my sense of the
future because they are, you know,
they're bulldozing the past as fast as
it can and we're headed racing into the
future. And so, uh,
I want to see what Asia has in store
for us because mathematically we don't
count anymore.
The whatever, the 3 billion Asians
and you know, 300 million Americans,
what can you say?
Yeah, that's right. So steady up folks.
Specialization is for insects.
I think that was Heinlein.
So enjoy your time on this planet and
look broadly like, like Kevin said, Kevin,
thank you so much. I will talk to you
soon and, uh, have a wonderful day.
I'll talk to you soon. Thanks for
having me too. Okay, bye. Bye.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes or go to for our blog.com
where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much, much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com
slash t Ferris,
that's t ISS or on Facebook
at facebook.com/tim Ferriss.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.